so Hank I just voted early here in
Indiana and I got this sticker that says
I vote count now I may not have perfect
grammar but I'm almost positive that I
vote count isn't a sentence but I'm
thinking maybe they like cutoff
something at the bottom like obviously I
vote count isn't a sentence but maybe
what they meant to say was I vote Count
Chocula so obviously Hank I didn't do my
question Tuesday video last week which
means I'm going to get punished now you
may be wondering why I'm doing my happy
dance it's because you're gonna get
punished - that's right Hank number one
you lost the peeps contest even though
technically you didn't participate and
number two last week you made a video
that was more than four minutes long
that didn't include a photo montage and
everyone knows that the vlogbrothers are
not allowed to make videos of more than
four minutes unless there's a montage so
nerdfighters please leave suggestions
for how we should be punished in
comments should it be a shared
punishment should it be some kind of
like dual punishment I don't know we've
never had a simultaneous punishment
before but now belatedly on two simple
questions Paper Towns dedicated to the
nerdfighters or no no although you are
in the acknowledgments what's your
favorite reference book about Islam no
god but God by reza aslan who would win
a fight between a Lockhart and Libba
Bray surprisingly Maureen Johnson we
ever write a sequel to one of your books
probably not but I might write a sequel
to a non-existent book who's your
favorite German writer me just getting
Goethe Goethe has individual sentences
that Poe in my entire body of work plus
Goethe would have never said pwned
what's your favorite book title to add
in your pants - at the moment I'm pretty
fond of Amy Krauss Rosenthal's little
pee in your pants I'm interested in
conjoined twins what are your favorite
books on the subject boy have you come
to the right place I'm one of the few
people who own more books about
conjoined twins then there are actual
conjoined twins living in the world
my favorite conjoined twins non-fiction
one of us by alice Drager favorite
fiction i'm not going to go with the
obvious pick I'm gonna go with God's
fool by Marx Luca who is the most
interesting author you've ever met I
find Judy Blume very interesting how
long is Paper Towns um if you count the
acknowledgments it's 308 pages if you
could write a biography of any famous
person who would it be Hank what's going
on with those people who are trying to
ban Looking for Alaska the made of
awesome School Board of Depew New York
voted unanimously to keep Alaska in the
coulomb if you and Hank were characters
in the book into thin air would you
survive I mean absolutely unambiguously
no I would die on the walk to Everest
how come your website is called sparks
fly up calm it's taken from a line in
the book of Job man is born to trouble
like the sparks fly upwards if the Yeti
were a vampire would you want her to
bite you so that you could spend
eternity together
well first off your question presumes
that I'm not a vampire which offends me
I mean how do you know that I'm not a
vampire
I'm very pale I've got bronze hair I
mean I'd be pretty fat for a vampire but
it's totally possible is there a book in
print you wish you'd written yes I wish
I'd written all of them I mean think how
rich I would be if I'd written every
book in print what's your favorite
personification of death in literature
it's in the Andrew Marvell poem to his
coy mistress who is not yet in his pants
any favorite poets other than Walt
Whitman and kisses are a better fate
than wisdom lady I swear by all flowers
I like a martini too at the very most
after three I'm under the table after
four I'm under the host I see thee
better in the dark I do not need a light
where is the Langston Hughes book what
is the point of having a catalog home
library when I can't find Langston
Hughes what are your favorite last words
from an author Emily Dickinson's last
words were pretty good she said I must
go in the fog is rising but my favorite
last words related author story is this
Edna st. Vincent Millay died by tumbling
down a flight of stairs her head landed
on a poem that she'd been working on the
last line of that poem beautiful this
day no matter who has died what do you
think Shakespeare would vlog about the
poor quality of insults on YouTube by
the way nerdfighters for punishing me
you're a bunch of fat kidney gudgeons
that's right I called you a gudgeon
what's your opinion on Catcher in the
Rye it's excellent and if you disagree
with me and I say this respectfully
you're wrong what's your favorite line
in Hamlet the rest is silence